walk him to this video playing yog Burt
Grandmaster leubronn one of the frequent
opponents and he's got a great score 62
against me he's really a strong player
very powerful if you give him some
attack especially on the King not good
yeah well this is seven this is not a
great line for white but it's the type
of line that he excels in getting the
center from a pawn and then going for an
attack he's really a good in this type
of type of positions okay let's see what
f6f six
yeah I know Queen a shrine I'm still not
sure g6 Knight takes pawn takes Queen
takes a Jedi take g5 mm-hmm
the end I've got Queen 85 I'm not sure
I'm not sure at all I don't want that I
rather return upon for for a decent
position and now I'm i was thinking
Queenie five but I actually forgot that
this Bishop is not hanging yeah well
anyway it wasn't a bad idea I mean I
gained some time and looks like like a
decent game night XD for its no
possibility he needs to reckon with he
cannot easily protect it with m3 because
of cui g3 check and you cannot protect
it with the bishop as well so he just
allows Queen g3 yeah okay come on check
I mean this if this must be must be okay
i mean the the king only 1 D 2 let's see
e 6 opening up the position come on I
need to open up him
gasps man she's a really strong player
the only weakness of think that team
it's not a weakness really but something
that sometimes helps you to help you to
some extent as he's very ambitious
always trying to go for your throat and
sometimes he is risking too much this is
probably okay I mean but it's it is
risky no doubt about that getting the
King to d2 I'm three threatening to open
up now on d5 maybe there should be seven
first something ok I'm on the night
takes knight takes Bishop e3 no let's
play more aggressively intending a five
if you play see five himself my bishop
gets opened up on b7 and I have queen
dee 5 very nice square for the Queen
should I go there yep I guess so I have
before and night a form those kind of
ideas and it's not easily getting rid of
the Queen I don't see how
maybe yeah proc t1 with rook do you want
coming
look very complicated as usual you never
get to get an easy game against the sky
it's always it's always tough the ideas
Bishop takes takes was check at a two
hanging this is so what's my point
check
he defended that if I take him
this one looks good you should be 555 he
cannot take on before yeah come on this
must be good now don't tell me you have
a great defense now that I didn't see
check
Bishop takes check in turn no Queen he
cannot move the porn at all check
white noise ah yeah Team B one would be
eight finally I got him at least once
yeah this is winning right I don't don't
see a move at all yeah rock da to avoid
the immediate mate yeah I think I played
I played it to to him to Bush asleep but
it seems that that I'm in good shape
here in this position the computer
already gives white almost losing
position yeah well I said that it's not
so easy to protect the poem but in fact
it's it seems impossible to do so how
are you protected I saw this idea but I
wasn't really sure that white doesn't
have a move it seems like he's in
trouble really yeah then this idea to
return the pawn is probably quite good
this really looks check it looks insane
victim down by a player a play very
computer reshef computer wants to do all
those moves now it wants to take on c3
even stronger than 93 but it is it is
really good I mean check king be one is
stronger compared to that oh here here
he missed the results c4 c4 keeps the
game going computer evaluation 000 tetas
great yeah it sees the perpetual check
oopsie a truck t3 Roxy for night takes
and now Bishop g5 9 f8 and now rook de
force a perpetual got the love computer
chess how is it a perpetual let's let's
check this check check
and have no I cannot play for we know
what no like King to f7 with Roxy c8
coming up let's just check this yeah it
seems white candy hand with this move
yeah just too wacky well the way it was
played chat with King be too I think
he's after Oh LC for he could have bled
see forward now no it's lost lost really
okay well I'm glad to have finally won
against the skype so still a bad score
but at least a win once and one alright
thanks for watching